jean-luc identified since 1959 I was I  was a student in Paris in 1960 when  breathless opened American girls took  off their pantego dolls and started  reading Kyoto cinema Gaddar had stripped  away classical all classical restraints  and we all went skinny-dipping at some  point he said photography is truth  cinema is truth twenty four times per  second he demanded that we have  something truthful to say as filmmakers  cinema verite was a religion and I  walked right into it when I discovered  documentary filmmaking speaking of truth  and religion there's no question Gaddar  has been an irreverent prophet  provocateur for his entire career but he  never used his art to promote bigotry  and that's a key distinction that I had  to understand so that I could honor him  tonight aside from his genius Godard  dared us to misbehave both as grown-ups  and as artists he is still misbehaving  and I'd like to think tonight is the  first time we've ever given an Oscar for  it  you